run fast and don't stop
[Music]
yes joseph how you doing
hello can you hear me can you see me and
i can great to see you again man
very good well thanks for calling so
good to speak with you again
the last time we spoke how long ago was
that like
do you remember i think two weeks ago
i think it was two weeks and when we
spoke you sold
how many deals and you know what i had
to check it now
and i checked my messages it was three
deals that time yeah you
and you were talking about 2 000 i think
on average you've made about five or six
grand and you said you had another
couple
potentially in the bag exactly i was
it was so exciting for me you know
because it was three deals
but i could not expect what happened
afterwards and then you literally
messaged me and we're like
you haven't put the youtube video out
yet let's do a quick catch up because i
made some more money so tell me what's
happened since
so well i guess um
that's a similar feeling like on wall
street
when you have several investors calling
you and uh
every social media channel is uh you
know
beeping up at the same time and
basically what happened i have sold
five more deals very quickly in a matter
of days
and uh two days ago another buy to let
which is now in the process the investor
is doing his due diligence and so on
so i had a goal to reach 10 000 if you
remember i i text
i posted on the group if i make 10 000
you have to take me for winners on
wednesday
yeah it's 11 500 now just
congrats massive massive massive news
that's so good
so and and and honestly it really really
is impressive stuff
like what advice would you give to
someone watching this that's wanting to
do the same
exactly you see um find
find a solution for a problem you know
find people who need your help
because the big reason why um i could
have this success right now is because
there are so many landlords
sitting with empty properties and you
know they need their properties
to be tenanted and then there are
investors who are looking for
for great deals in the city center in
great locations so
why not to be there to help them and
make the connection and help them with
the process
so instead of sitting at home and
waiting for something to happen
uh communicate and you are a great
example of that uh
actually you are the best one who people
can take advice
from this because all you do is
communication you put your message out
you help so many people
and you know once you keep communicating
something else will come in and you
never know who is that person who will
need your help
that's great so what's your backstory by
the way where where are you from i'm
trying to work out your
your your wonderful european twang or
something going on
yes well i'm originally from slovakia
right if you don't know slovakia is a
country in the middle of europe
and we used to be czechoslovakia before
so
prague maybe is a city that rings isabel
or my city is braggislava
as a slovakian and i have traveled
all over the world i lived for a year in
new zealand
i lived in denmark for six years and now
i'm trying to get it work in scotland
for the last three years basically
we're living right now in edinburgh
right edinburgh yeah because i remember
you at the edinburgh crash course which
is crazy that was literally like two
months or so ago that was it
it was so cool you came up with arister
and all the team
yeah and we wanted you up here and then
it was great how was that how was the
crash course netting before
you um it was amazing again met so many
new people
uh you know made new contacts it's so
good to see when people are
um you know they come there with an open
mind you know
we have to admit that property can be a
complicated thing and
uh it's not something that you learned
in school or anywhere else
so the crash course is a great way to
start and to get a basic understanding
and again we refreshed all the data
all the strategies uh we looked for some
really good deals
if you remember it was a good game to
find the best deal a couple of good
teams
yeah and uh made good connections crash
course is the crash course you know it's
only one crash course
what what's your biggest tip for
building an investor list how have you
managed to grow your
in list of investors good question
that's the hardest for
i i guess for every source that's the
hardest and
be present on social media and be
present physically everywhere on all the
networking groups
and now if you ask you remember you made
a video about
um that you are looking for investors
and i had seen it on facebook and i say
oh okay i might just do the same so i
did the same kind of ad
and i got about 45 50 new investors on
the list
yeah and from those a couple of them are
in communication with me already and
signed up for bespoke
sourcing so you have to be present
everywhere
and tell people what you do what about
the ones that are buying from you where
they come from
um from the investors list is where the
investors list whereas
i'm trying to get to the the source so
people can copy and do the same okay
so um every time i had the deal i had
promoted it everywhere on social media
that you know i have such a property and
and of course direct them to my mailing
list
so i have constantly you know try to
build a large
or as large as possible mailing list as
possible you know
and these investors comes from there
because what's happening you know they
see that you constantly send out some
deals
they see that you are working doing your
job so sooner or later
either of those investors on your own
facebook are you getting into into the
facebook groups and tap into community
on my facebook on groups yeah everywhere
every every possible action you know but
i never post an actual deal
i just say i have it because i know i
know on most groups
you're not allowed to just post a deal
so how do you get around that
ah okay now i got your point is um you
know it's not like
you post that you have a specific deal
and then people will suddenly call you
it's not like that
but you never know when there is a
communication in a group
about certain property deals where you
can contribute
you know maybe there are questions about
rent usa's or about buy to let's
and if you as a forcer have a knowledge
about that
uh you can jump into a conversation and
contribute
and that way you know you get interest
of others what you do
it all goes back to adding value again
like
you're saying if you go onto a facebook
group
the best strategy is to contribute find
people asking questions
on the group answer their questions and
then people think oh that was helpful he
knows what he's talking about
and then they'll and then they'll get
chatting with you and say well what do
you actually do oh well actually i'm a
deal sorcerer edinburgh
okay i might be interested in some deals
could you drop me a pm
so is that kind of like what you're
talking about
exactly absolutely exactly as you're
saying i'm not feeling very active
i've seen you i know i'm certainly not
on my on my community
i've seen you very active what are some
of the other communities that where
you've been getting deals from
oh there are some other networking
groups also on whatsapp
you know where investors are present and
also i would say other resources can be
helpful
because you might find someone who is
actively sourcing deals but
he is not in your area he might have an
investor who maybe
wants to buy in your area so where do
you find these guys
where do you find these other sources
going deep in it
uh i would say facebook groups and also
your group uh you know property
investors with samuel is there are so
many people who are actively working
serious investors
what percentage of your investors that
have paid you would you say have come
from my facebook group
out of interest well if i couldn't
charge a commission or anything you've
worked for it so
all right so i see where are you getting
look
to be honest the first two serious
investors
who bought one person he bought a
property
another uh bought rent-to-rent deals
where from york
what about the ref um in the rest
also from personal contacts from
you know like networking groups where i
go in person and
we meet also some locals you know people
from edinboro and around who knows me
and who has heard something about me
no every single person who's got access
to these face
to mind certainly to my facebook group
it's a free group
but and it's the same with money people
say
like money is unlimited everybody has
access to money
everybody has access to the 27 thousand
investors on my group
everyone has access to deals online
the difference is some people will sit
on the fence
and talk and observe and other people
would just jump in
pull their sleeves up add value and do
so there's no
and the reason i was asking you about
getting really nitty-gritty into the
specifics was because
because the answer is it just shows that
anyone can do it you don't belong to
some secret
property society where i've given you a
green pass
and like everybody has access
there are no excuses that's exactly
right that's exactly right you know take
action
it's easy to say but um once you start
doing
it and you keep up you keep being
persistent you know
people will start to take you serious
they will get um you know they will get
to you
the same as the crash course you came to
the crash course everybody has access to
the crash course people can sit on the
fence and think oh is it gonna be worth
my time
what's gonna just go
exactly there's so much you know
negativity in the world these days and
um the question is is that help me in
any way if i take on negative stuff will
that
will that push me forward in life no it
will not
so why not go and meet people who are
positive who can
whatever are the current circumstances
you know um
despite of the coronavirus and anything
else
people who can see something positive
and make some steps forward you know i
like that i like
positive people i like when there is
motivation in life in the game you know
we
we are not going to diet you know i
agree and i also think that
um other people's success so you
becoming successful
is also my success and i really believe
that
when you think in a mindset of other
people's success
is my success and i want others to win
rather than thinking from a scarce
mentality and thinking there's only so
many deals i'm going to keep everything
close to my chest
and i want to win alone listen number
one you won't win and number two even if
you do win a loan you're going to be
very lonely
that's right
and to want other people to win to
celebrate other people's successes
i think that's just absolutely certainly
the way i live and i know it's the way
you live as well
that's right and you see what i would
say uh from my experience
in the past i had other businesses and
been in different nature basically
the property is the only one that i have
experienced where people help each other
so much
there is so much support you know um i
cooperate with other dual sources and
we don't compete we help each other you
know
so it's really the best thing for me
myself personally was the best decision
i have made
and i remember i spoke shortly with
alistair at the dfe in november
and i told him that you know it's it
just
i just can't believe that you send out a
deal and you get a text message and you
sell it you know
it was like i actually forgot joseph i
know you've told me already but i forgot
that you'd actually done some of our
advanced training because you came to
the crash course but that wasn't your
first crash course
no it was the third one the first one
was last year
you did the advanced training and you
did the whole you saw us sell deals you
watched to sell deals from the stage
what was that like tell me through that
experience
there was there was the experience it
was emotional
it was crazy it was um
full of energy and i just couldn't
believe it's real
i say really you can like what i have
been doing wrong the whole 10 years
you know and when it happened to me the
first time that i have sell the
you know send the deal out and the text
message came in
i took the phone walked through the
investor about the deal and actually
they sent the money on my account i was
it was unbelievable you know i say
that's that's the way i want to go
and i want to build it further for the
future because
um you know at least at the moment i'm
almost alone i have some helpers and i
cooperate with other people but
it can be easily made to a well
sustained business
you know exactly as alistair has it's
amazing anyone who doesn't know who
alastair is alex there is one of my
students
who's become very successful and now
he's been so successful that i've
actually brought him on as a trainer
and he now teaches people and you've met
alice that you've seen him work you've
seen him train
and i think one of the things i say at
the crash course is i say listen man
when you start doing the
the advanced training like the deal
selling mastery and different things
like and you see me and my trainers and
you see deals being sold live in front
of your eyes once you've seen that you
can't
unsee that and then once you you
did you get that exactly exactly
and i say if if that's you know if that
is how how it works
like if that's true then i might as well
just try and
do whatever i can and see i can make it
you know and if i can make it
with uh maybe not even 100 english or
being here in the country for a very
short time then i believe everyone can
make it you know
when when when you know how to make like
2 000 pounds
from just finding a deal passing me on
like that's not i'm not saying it's not
a lot of work because a lot of work goes
into it
but most people spend a month working
for two or three months
when you can just pass a deal on like
it's just why would you work your ass
off
for a month in a job that you don't like
and recover on the weekends ready to go
back to your miserable life which is
monday i'm not saying there's anything
wrong with jobs
but if you hate your job just be a deal
saucer
come on yeah and you know
there are so many strategies deal
sourcing rent to rent there are
more strategies where you don't have to
have a lot of money to get involved
right
um and for me personally view sourcing
was the most closest because
uh even in past my jobs were always
somewhere um you know as a manager i
always manage something and
being in the middle between people
employees and
and clients and so on your sourcing is
very similar because you have your
investors and you have your
landlords you have your you know source
of properties
and i thought that that something could
work for me
and you know i kept the same strategy
for a long time
it's now well above seven months i'm
doing it actively full time
it's not like i have been skipping from
one strategy to another
and that's also something that worked
for me well you know
and maybe in the future i definitely uh
want to have my own portfolio
i definitely want to have experience
with all kind of strategies
uh buy to let i want to experience a
full referral
project and so on you've done the right
thing though because listen
you you sometimes it's easy to be when
especially when you start doing training
to be like a kid in a candy shop and
they're oh that sounds like that's
amazing that's amazing it's actually
indicated now
focus on one course until successful
that's the definition of focus
so like just kill it in one area
and then also what you'll find is as
well joseph which you're probably
already beginning to find
is your strategies they all over link so
when you're deal sorting your packaging
because you might be like
actually i'm going to keep this deal
myself and
you might be chatting to someone to to
get a below market value deal
and then you find actually they can't
accept it because they're negative
equity
i may be able to offer this and then you
go to offer them a lease option and you
think
actually i'll keep it and it just i i
think deal sourcing is
a great way to start because then what
happens it gives you such an experience
and
a network of all these different deals
and stuff and then suddenly they start
overlapping and you can start doing
different deals
exactly and i remember you said on crash
course that
once you can source deals properly you
know how to find and qualify those
properties
identify them then you can do
any strategy you want because you will
have understanding of
how rent to rent works how what's needed
for our refer project and all that we
went through on the dfe
where we detailed you know checked every
single strategy so
we can i can just anytime go back to it
and see um what strategy i'm working on
now for the investor and just
follow the steps so yeah it's it's very
simple actually
it's really simple that's great what why
do you sourcing them because
of all the different strategies you
chose deal sourcing to start with what
do you think so great about
being a deal sourcer and that strategy
in general
um good question you know i just spoke
with my friend a couple of days ago
about the same thing and um i consider
myself
now at this time um like very active
i like to work i like the idea of having
passive income
and just sit back and do nothing and
earn those money every month
but maybe it will come later at this
time maybe for the first
couple of years two three years i like
to put myself in it
experience you know the problems the
investors the situations
and be there to manage it and just run
it through like
what makes me feel very happy and
satisfied is when
i can see a quick result you know it's
quick
it's you find the deal you find an
investor a couple of problems you handle
everything and then you have
win-win situation and it's quick and you
can repeat it two three four times a
month
in that case well that's something i
really like because it's energetical
it's uh it's going fast um like i have a
friend
she is a property investor and they do
refurbishment projects on a regular
basis
and they do one two houses a year you
know it takes time to find the house to
go through all the process
refurbish it and so on and that's fine
that's
that's totally fine but for me i rather
take the action
you know work hard and see the results
quick so that's one of the reasons why i
am a deal sorcerer because i like it
that way basically yeah
that makes sense it's i guess i i i
wouldn't want to go down the route of
get rich quick but you can definitely
make cash quick
you know what do you think about the um
compliance side of things i mean i
personally think people
way over complicate the compliance and
try and make it deliberately difficult
i totally agree with you you know in the
end of the day
okay compliance is very important but
when we look at the contracts and all
the paperwork basically
the basic question is that i am there to
work for an investor
and the question is am i able to make
him satisfied you know am i able to make
him happy with the process
if i am able then it's fine to have all
the papers
but but that's the main point if i'm not
able to satisfy an investor
or if my job is dodgy and you know i'm
not a pro
proper deal sorcerer i can have all kind
of contracts in place it won't help me
because i will lose my reputation oh
true i mean honestly for a start i think
a lot of what people
say about compliance is is
over the top but you know
another thing the whole system with
compliance
you know the ico the prs and stuff like
that it all
makes very much sense it's naturally
many of those things if if you are
thinking uh
with the same mind you would anyway do
like for example with
the data protection if the investor
gives you his bank account you wouldn't
go around and show other people hey look
how many millions he has got you know of
course you keep it safe and so on
so many of those compliance things are
very
um like it makes sense to do anyway
you know yeah it does and also as well i
mean don't get me wrong anyone that's
watching this that thinks i'm saying
compliance is not important i'm not
saying that what i'm saying is
the most important thing is giving value
to your investor and finding good deals
because as you just said joseph like
if if you you can you can have a nice
company set up you can have all the
insurances you can have a beautiful logo
you can have a fancy website
you can have flyers business cards you
can have a really nice
um seo campaign going on all this stuff
but if you haven't got deals and you
haven't got investors or
you haven't got a good reputation
because you sell bad deals to investors
like that's that's what you need you
need deals investors you need a good
reputation and you need to be able to
sell
that's right do that then yeah of course
you're gonna need to run the business
legally and you're gonna need to make
sure you've got you know you have got
the correct things in place but let's
not let the tail wag
the dog here yes that's that's exactly
right and
at the beginning i spend a lot of time
with compliance well a lot of time
maybe a week but but still a lot of time
and i made sure i have every documents
in place
all the registrations everything that
was needed i got it done you know
alistair
again i need to mention him he has a
book or whatever it takes
yeah um it goes over in detail the
compliance
so does we even wrote a book actually we
wrote a book called uh i think it's
called property
compliance or something like that yes
that's the new one
you've wrote it with the team from i
can't take too much credit i didn't
i i i headed it up and i did a little
bit of intro and stuff but
most of the work was my students because
to be honest um
you know i didn't want to write a book
on compliance but i knew that it was
important so i kind of pulled some of my
students into it and they did a
anthony hannah james yeah guys
oh geez there's four and now i'm now
now i'm going to feel awful because i
forgot you know find it out on amazon
just type amazon samuel
and uh it's so easy you know
it's nothing complicated and anyone who
wants to do deal sourcing can
easily find out these details you know
and just do it and you can find it for
free
you don't need to pay a mentor to teach
you about compliance that's why i wrote
a book on it
because i thought i don't want people to
pay me
good money and then like can you teach
me about compliance i'm like no
when you let me money i want you to say
to me how do i build my investor list
how do i sell a deal how do i
that's what i want you to ask me i don't
want you to ask me these questions you
can just find out on the internet before
right
yeah exactly exactly so compliance
that's fine it's done that's there
and of course i have to comply with all
these but
the most important is to be able find
the deals you know and i
i tell you something that might be
interesting for um other deal sources
out there who are struggling
and maybe um maybe it can help them
is that basically you need to give it
some time
you know maybe one two three months
until your name is out there
and investors can get to you and then
we will reach a point where deals will
come to you kind of automatically
because
because your area will know that you are
the guy
at least i think i have the reputation
that uh people in my area knows
that i work with investors from
everywhere
that i have access to investors from
overseas maybe
and so whenever there is a deal or a
property that they need help with to
sell quickly for example they come to me
joseph could you could you offer this to
your investors is it something you would
like
so you know over time it will come might
be hard at the beginning it will be hard
it was for me
yeah i i used to give up weekly i used
to give up every week and i said okay i
will give up
but let's just do one more week let's do
whatever it takes for a week
and i will give up next week you know
wow that's really powerful
that's used to regularly quit but then
you just start again and then quit and
then start again until you
that's well that's a good job that
alastair wrote his book whatever it
takes
yeah because you got to keep on keep
getting back on the horse it's the same
if you're learning a new skill for me it
might be easy and sometimes
you know if i do a financial freedom
challenge and i'll be i'll make like
eight grand in a week
yeah people need to remember yeah but
i've got over
10 years experience like if
you're learning to walk for the first
time you crawl for a bit then you
fall and you get up and you're falling
but but then once you can do it you can
do it and i think like with you now
if i wiped you from everything that you
had all your money all your everything
guaranteed
with your knowledge your confidence your
experience you get where you're up to
now
like 10 times faster probably times
faster because you've done it
and you know how to do it and no one can
ever take that from you
that's the thing exactly as you say
totally true
that's great so listen man as we wrap up
final words of advice to anyone watching
this that wants to
emulate the success that you've had um
don't hesitate you know don't hesitate
think positively open your
mind and get some new uh knowledge you
know
get in contact you offer you do crash
courses online now
um so there is plenty of ways how to get
knowledge about
properties and how to do deal sourcing
you know and really if i can do it
anyone can do it so
just get knowledge you know get some
advice from people who are really doing
it you know
that's great and and your name is joseph
with a zed
yes
all right i'll put like uh i i'll put
like a link or something of your website
as well in the description of this if
you
assume you've got a website if you if
you want to find joseph as well you can
find him i know he's very you'll
definitely find him in the facebook
group i'll put a link to the facebook
group you can connect with him on there
and uh joseph really really proud of you
man good to see you kicking ass
and i look forward to seeing what what
the future brings for you over the
rest of the year thank you so much
samuel also for everything you do for
all of us
uh starters and do well and take care
and just be
as much energical as you are always so
all the best to you
thank you my friend see you soon see you
bye bye